I thought you just had to be drunk as
[ __ ] but even that's a little tough
though cuz you can't call it like I've
been man the first time I didn't get up
was the scare have you ever been in that
position whiskey dick yes yes that [ __ ]
will [ __ ] you up mint I didn't know what
whiskey dick was I thought I thought my
[ __ ] was broken yeah you're like okay
cuz you're like I'm horny like I feel
like I feel like I could do something I
found about whiskey dick through like a
sitcom they were making a joke about it
yeah and then uh is that some [ __ ] cuz
you know you boys don't ever talk about
this you don't talk about we talk about
all of our accolades and how how good we
are [ __ ] and I was always the awkward
kid because I didn't have sex till I was
18
yeah but everybody in my group was
[ __ ] when they were like 14 13 yeah
no I haven't Nelson yeah so they were
talking about [ __ ] where I would just
sit in the corner
yeah man [ __ ] is just like that you
know I had no idea like a nice like warm
mitten
yeah you have a [ __ ] take like a
[Laughter]
flower out the pot and put your dick in
the soil you know that [ __ ] forty old
virgin in that in the beginning [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was me man yep titty feels
like a bag don't because whereas that's
the [ __ ] fucked-up part about young
guys whereas we're so scared to be like
hey I haven't had sex yet you're gonna
get [ __ ] roasted why why not getting
roasted cuz y'all out here do it having
sex I want you to just help me like hey
this is like this is what it is but
you're afraid to say we did a
vulnerability with men just don't go
together yeah don't go together yeah but
if a dude I think this is I mean I think
people nowadays are a lot more
vulnerable yeah yeah you know I think in
our generation and then we go all even
older like I feel like if you were
vulnerable you're gonna have a heart
attack like I couldn't do it they would
just die on the spot they talk about the
feelings they were just [ __ ] down is
bad that was it yeah I say this all the
time my father has never said I'm sorry
to me my mother my mom has never said
I'm sorry
she doesn't even know what that word
means it's just tough love yeah and
that's what we grow up having and then
we get with somebody and they're like
why are you being like that you know uh
you know what I don't know let me figure
yeah I need to figure that out like is
why is a vein popping out here but yeah
say I'm sorry
are you okay like but no I was I like I
I definitely am NOT I've had the
whiskey-dick before but the first the
very first time it happened to me I was
with I was I think I was overly excited
and nervous
Oh which is a whole nother level because
it was a girl then I was asked I was
like 22 I was after her after and she
wouldn't give me no time of day and then
one day she calls me out my sleep and
it's like hey what's going on and I'm
like oh hello or she's like oh I'm
leaving the club huh could I come by I'm
immediately excited yeah
yeah that's fine I'm now I'm up like
yeah whatever they had a pep talk with
mother [ __ ] about the hello then I
hang up the phone
hop in the shower I'm sure I'm still
[ __ ] sleepy I just got walking out on
my sleeves I'm not all right [ __ ] all
right get it together she's coming she
gets there she looks good I'm all right
we get excited we in there we kissing
gotta die I put the condom on and she
said you look good man you hit that [ __ ]
wrong that's tight I think that's broad
that's the ultimate debate for me it's
just like because you you shouldn't
always use protection always protect
your trash use it because it's safe but
let's really be honest about it here -
it is it's not natural we just like
every time I had that [ __ ] I'm just like
you [ __ ] you better goddamn I
don't know about this [ __ ] I'm like I
don't know about this and I'm always
just there just right every man has been
in this position right here you're about
to have sex the condom is right there
and you're looking at her she's looking
at you you try to figure out alright cuz
if I just about to go in here it's two
things can happen she could be like hey
what the [ __ ] are you doing or she could
just let me go but I know for sure
that's the safest route over there yeah
every guy's been never since we like or
when you get in there raw and you like I
shouldn't be doing
you know what's dope it's like if you if
when you were about to [ __ ] and the
girls it's like hey you need to use a
condom cuz I don't really know you like
that I'm like oh that means you're clean
and I'm like I'm clean I'm clean as [ __ ]
yeah yeah like I just got tested it's
like don't we're both good you know but
that conversation never goes out too
well and yeah the reason why she stays
clean reason why you stay clean that's
because using the contrary use a kind of
if it's real [ __ ] you know what you know
what a condom is condom is like eating
halo ice cream you know it's like it's
good it's good for what it does you know
I mean but it's not the same as ice
cream like a fox with halo I say yeah
because it's like every vegan option
yeah that's exactly pretty solid so this
is dope
but I know like impossible but yeah I
know the imposter burger tastes good but
ain't no regular burger yeah if I old
every confident when I was a youth
minister something these kids me so
[ __ ] funny man like Iron Man this kid
came up to me he took me aside and goes
you know no pads can I ask you something
you know I just I really want to have
sex you know like I have this girl that
I like you know but is it wrong if I
just have sex once and then I repent and
not have smells like let me tell you
something my child yeah once you get in
there you're never gonna want to come
out yeah you're gonna realize how trash
your hand is compared to a [ __ ] like
you will never ever know that you're
never that's theirs because that's home
for us we came from there yeah that's
awesome
you're the kid that went you went to
Afghanistan and then you get that you
came back home you're coming back home
and you want it to welcome you come here
like yeah it hugs you yeah like it's so
awesome I was like remember before [ __ ]
you were you know all about just like
fun kid [ __ ] who's living life eat a
pizza with your friends you know I'm
saying like go to school the minute you
have [ __ ] your life starts to just talk
I used to read books before I had [ __ ]
if it starts to go down here to read but
what's the book now you open the booklet
old [ __ ] opens but what I do is I take
an aloe plant again I slice it it happen
it's really true like like you cuz that
wasn't once you have it man as a young
man our hormones go no man I don't miss
that [ __ ] no no no that was correct that
is all you thought about like wake up in
the morning [ __ ] go to bed
that's all you do you like what is wrong
with me like there's some there's some
people who - by the way that we're
questionably number one unattractive at
all accounts yes physically personality
wise but the fact that she just had a
[ __ ] and I was like you know what she
probably was went through a lot of [ __ ]